[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos hay lugares a los cuales tamaño
no les hace justicia por ejemplo fijaos
en el caso de singapur a pesar de ser
relativamente pequeño es un gigantesco
polo económico a nivel regional e
incluso mundial un enorme núcleo de
actividad económica que no sólo atrae
capitales y empresas sino también a un
montón de trabajadores que en su mayor
parte proceden de malasia y es
precisamente en este país en malasia
donde junto a singapur se puso en marcha
en 2006 un proyecto salvaje la
construcción desde cero de toda una
ciudad proyectada para tener al menos
700 mil habitantes y que está situada
sobre cuatro islas artificiales es decir
en terrenos ganados al mar hablamos de
forest city uno de los proyectos más
ambiciosos y sorprendentes que ahora
mismo podemos encontrar en todo el mundo
ahora bien si sois fieles seguidores de
visual polític sabréis que esto de
construir nuevas ciudades como si fuesen
juguetes del ego no es algo extraño ni
siquiera algo poco habitual bueno y es
que de hecho vamos a ver tiene bastante
sentido porque al fin y al cabo cada vez
nuestro mundo es un mundo más urbano
vivimos cada vez más en un planeta de
ciudades los números no engañan
mientras que a día de hoy
aproximadamente el 56 por ciento de toda
la población mundial vive en zonas
urbanas para el 2050 este porcentaje se
prevé que suba hasta casi el 70% lo que
evidentemente supone un enorme reto las
ciudades que ya existen tienen sus
límites por recursos espacios servicios
o capacidad de las infraestructuras es
decir no pueden expandirse sin límites
por eso en muchas partes del mundo donde
la urbanización está siendo más rápida
que en europa y américa la solución a la
que se está llegando es a la de
construir nuevas ciudades completamente
desde cero nuevos entes llamados a
funcionar de una forma más eficiente ya
lograr mejores desempeños económicos y
esto esto es precisamente lo que se
pretende con el proyecto de forest city
pero esperar un momento porque caso de
forest city es un poco especial su
localización ha sido elegida
exclusivamente por la existencia de
singapur como si se tratase de toda una
expansión malaya de la ciudad-estado
amigos en este vídeo os vamos a contar
todos los detalles sobre este gigantesco
proyecto un proyecto tan extraño como
polémico en el que os sorpresa ser así
tiene mucha tela que cortar os apetece
viajar con nosotros a este rincón del
mundo y conocer no solo lo bonito sino
también el lado más polémico de esta
nueva ciudad y en general de este tipo
de proyectos pues arranquemos un
dormitorio de singapur o una expedición
china fijaos un momento en esta imagen
[Música]
como veis prácticamente todo el
territorio continental al norte de
forest city está vacío y estoy seguro de
que sois muchos los que justo en este
preciso momento os estáis preguntando
entonces por qué gastarse una millonada
en crear islas artificiales y ganarle
terreno al mar en lugar de levantar el
proyecto en suelo continental en tierras
del estado de johor pues porque la idea
es esta
veréis para crear la ciudad soñada a un
nuevo modelo de desarrollo urbano que
sea ejemplo del mundo entero y que llame
la atención de los inversores no puede
haber ningún obstáculo posible problemas
con la propiedad problemas con la
distribución del suelo regulaciones así
que nueva ciudad es nuevo solo aunque no
sea estrictamente necesario así de
sencillo
ni siquiera esto es algo tampoco nuevo
la palmera de dubai por ejemplo es un
concepto parecido a mucha menor escala
eso sí pero bien dicho esto conozcamos
un poquito mejor este proyecto
[Música]
a simple vista aparece toda una
inversión de futuro hablamos de 14
kilómetros cuadrados de nueva ciudad
repartidos en cuatro islas 300.000
viviendas 700.000 habitantes 200 mil
empleos nuevos y al menos 100 mil
millones de dólares de inversión todo
esto en un horizonte de 30 años son
simple y llanamente cifras de infarto la
idea sobre el papel es aprovechar la
zona económica especial de scandar para
replicar el éxito de shenzhen una ciudad
china que como yo os hemos contado en
alguna que otra ocasión aquí en visual
político está localizada justo al otro
lado de la frontera con hong kong y
gracias a la aprobación de una zona
económica especial ya la influencia de
hong kong pasó de ser una pequeña
localidad de pescadores a convertirse en
el principal hub tecnológico de china y
no sólo eso se enseña es hoy en día una
de las ciudades chinas de mayor renta y
con mayor calidad de vida pues bien la
idea en el caso de forest city o quizás
la excusa es hacer lo mismo aprovechando
las similitudes que existen entre
singapur y hong kong
[Música]
y ojo porque esto es tal cual de hecho
el 66% de todo el consorcio que lo
promueve el llamado country garden
pacific view es propiedad del grupo
country garden group una de las
principales promotoras inmobiliarias
chinas con sede en foshan en la
provincia de guandong exactamente la
misma provincia en la que está sense
[Música]
vamos que conoce muy bien todo este caso
del desarrollo de shenzhen
[Aplausos]
y luego por cierto el otro 34 le
pertenece a la empresa local es planeta
tenga 88 de la cual curiosamente el
sultán de johor ibrahim ismail posee más
del 64 por ciento de las acciones vamos
preguntan es el accionista mayoritario
me habéis escuchado bien insultar de
johor porque amigos mala se tiene uno de
los sistemas políticos más extraño del
planeta nueve de los estados que forman
la federación tienen su propia casa real
de tal forma que el tal ibrahim ismail
es el sultán y jefe del estado de johor
de todas formas en un próximo vídeo ya
entraremos en detalles sobre este
particular galimatías este particular
rompecabezas que es el sistema político
malayo en cualquier caso como veis por
muy jefe del estado que sea pues no se
corta un pelo en hacer negocios aunque
sea buscando el pelotazo inmobiliario
tirando de influencia qué novedad verdad
[Música]
pero continuamos precisamente esa
participación mayoritaria de la empresa
china country garden group donde surge
la polémica sobre el propósito real de
este proyecto porque amigos este
proyecto ha sido abiertamente enmarcado
dentro de la archiconocida iniciativa
one by one road por la que como todos
sabéis el presidente chino xi jinping
busca expandir la influencia china a
base de
es mi oralidad en infraestructuras o
proyectos como éste del que os estamos
hablando en este vídeo de hecho como
curiosidad si miramos más de cerca como
es forest city al menos es la primera
fase que ya se ha construido lo que nos
encontramos es ni más ni menos con una
ciudad china en toda regla una ciudad
china en el corazón de malasia y a tan
sólo dos kilómetros de singapur
y
no se trata solo de que alrededor del
80% de los apartamentos vendidos los
hayan comprado ciudadanos chinos sino
también por cómo han sido pensados sus
servicios y sus espacios públicos por
ejemplo la única institución educativa
que actualmente está instalada en forest
city elsa tucson mervis forest city
international school un colegio
estadounidense ofrece educación
únicamente en dos idiomas inglés y chino
nada de malayo lo cual por otra parte
tiene todo el sentido del mundo pues
este lugar no ha sido pensado para los
malayos sino para que viva gente de
otros países un dato un pequeño
apartamento de dos habitaciones cuesta
alrededor de 170 mil dólares un precio
que no está al alcance de la inmensa
mayoría de los trabajadores malayos ni
siquiera para los que trabajan en
singapur
y ojo porque justo aquí es no surgido
todo un debate un debate acerca de la
soberanía real que subyace a este tipo
de proyecto está bien dejar que una
promotora extranjera construya y venda a
chinos la mayor parte de una ciudad de
casi un millón de habitantes y que
además se haga a imagen y semejanza de
la ciudad de china sin tener en cuenta
ni a la población ni en las
peculiaridades locales os invito a que
dejéis vuestra opinión aquí abajo en los
comentarios y si estoy seguro de que
muchos de vosotros no tendréis tan claro
que el medio de vatos parecerá una
auténtica pamplina pero lo cierto es que
si lo pensáis bien es el cóctel perfecto
para toda una campaña política la
influencia de xi jinping en el
nacionalismo malayo el peligro ante la
amenaza china
la falta de acceso para la población
local etcétera etcétera y ya lo tenemos
el caldo de cultivo perfecto para toda
una campaña política con tintes
nacionalistas y sabéis que eso es eso es
precisamente lo que está ocurriendo
hasta el punto de que puede convertirse
en uno de los principales escollos para
este proyecto y es que hoy por hoy los
políticos de malasia tienen con este
proyecto una especie de relación de amor
y odio veréis por un lado no les gusta
que se construye una ciudad china en su
territorio pero por otro tampoco se
hacen las cosas los más de 220 millones
si el estado de malasia ya ha ingresado
en conceptos como impuestos tasas y
licencias de bajas a este proyecto todo
este dinero ojo cuando ni siquiera una
cuarta parte del proyecto ha sido
completado
pero da igual a pesar del maní maní como
os decía antes el debate sorda sobran y
años se ha dejado de lado fijaos
construir una gigantesca ciudad china en
malasia no sólo genera dudas sobre
nuestra soberanía nacional sino sobre el
contrato social que debe de ser abordado
o habrá desequilibrios
lin wang en ex ministro de finanzas de
malasia y no es una opinión aislada sin
ir más lejos estas preocupaciones
llevaron al anterior gobierno al del
primer ministro mahathir mohamad a
eliminar las visas automáticas para
quien compras de propiedades en forest
city y que era uno de sus principales
atractivos es decir que ahora puedes
comprarte un apartamento pero no
disfrutar automáticamente de esa
propiedad
si eres extranjero bueno de hecho tal
fue el escepticismo del anterior primer
ministro que llegó incluso a decidir que
preferiría que forest city se
convirtiera en un bosque de verdad con
babuinos monos y demás bichos viviendo
por allí de locos pero por qué tantos
recelos por tanta controversia en torno
a un proyecto que nació con el objetivo
de convertirse en todo un orgullo
nacional y en un motor económico de
primera que el futuro le espera a esta
nueva mega ciudad que ya está en marcha
que se esconde tras el interés del
gobierno chino acaso hay algo oculto
detrás de todas las imponentes torres y
los vídeos promocionales que muestran
lugar casi como un paraíso pues atentos
[Música]
tras bambalinas
vale si algo está claro en toda esta
historia es que forest city existe y
está en el lugar donde está
exclusivamente por la existencia de
singapur la ciudad-estado ha servido en
este caso tal y como por otra parte
suele suceder casi siempre como todo un
flujo de atracción de inversión y
capital no sólo para la propia ciudad
sino también para la región que le rodea
que además en este caso es mucho pero
que mucho más pobre y es que aunque
forest city de completarse en los planes
tendrán un futuro próximo una gran zona
de oficinas actividades comerciales e
incluso zonas industriales que hoy
podrían llegar a rivalizar con la
mismísima singapur al menos según consta
en los planos la idea no va precisamente
por ahí
más bien de lo que se trata en este caso
es de acercar los tentáculos económicos
de china a la ciudad-estado un centro
económico de primer orden internacional
de esta manera no solo multitud de
chinos con el poder adquisitivo
suficiente como para comprarse una casa
claro sino también decenas y decenas
cientos de empresas chinas y miles de
profesionales podrán establecerse en
condiciones preferentes junto a singapur
es decir para que nos entendamos la idea
por la que el gobierno chino está
apoyando esta iniciativa es porque
supone construir toda una ciudad china
una ciudad adaptado y enfocada a la
población y los profesionales chinos
junto a la mismísima singapur y es que
de hecho la principal compañía promotora
a la china que entre garden es una
empresa que está especializada y
prácticamente dedicada en exclusiva a la
comercialización de espacios
inmobiliarios entre ciudadanos chinos
esto es entre otras cosas lo que explica
que los inversores en forest city sean
básicamente chinos por no decir que tan
sólo un puñado de malasios singapureses
indonesios coreanos algún que otro
japonés o hong kong es entre otros
pequeños grupos de nacionalidades han
comprado propiedades allí
es decir estamos hablando de lo que la
práctica puede llegar a ser todo un
potente clúster empresarial con el que
las empresas chinas logren una situación
privilegiada a la hora de hacer negocios
en singapur os lo imagináis no sé desde
colores en chino hasta abogados que
entiendan el marco jurídico de china
forest city se ha diseñado para hacer
como un punto de encuentro entre
profesionales que viven en singapur y el
mercado chino y si lo penséis un momento
es una sorprendente forma de extender la
influencia de la economía china una
forma por cierto tan sorprendente como
capitalista al fin y al cabo se basa la
inversión privada la rentabilidad y la
premisa de generar ventajas competitivas
para sus empresas y ojo al mismo tiempo
para malasia puede llegar a ser una
oportunidad de oro un tremendo motor
económico para desarrollar el sur del
país y convertirlo en toda una fuente de
riqueza claro que no todo es tan
sencillo
[Música]
el problema son las orgánicas y ojo no
es una cuestión precisamente menor os
imagináis no sé al gobierno chino
llegando a reclamar la soberanía de una
ciudad de la que viven cientos de miles
de ciudadanos chinos y que se ha
construido con capital chino yo juego
que con los procedentes de pekín en la
mano no parece algo tan descabellado
pues bien el caso es que a este digamos
problema político se unen otras
inquietudes que siempre siempre aparecen
con este tipo de proyectos por ejemplo
las quejas de la población local por el
impacto que esta ciudad puede tener en
el sector pesquero la actividad
económica de la que hoy por hoy viven
[Música]
como ya os hemos contado forest city se
está levantando sobre cuatro islas
ganadas al mar se encuentra enclavado
junto a la desembocadura del río pulite
donde está la reserva forestal del
manglares del río pool hay pues bien
debido al cambio la dinámica de mareas
que genera esta nueva costa artificial
muchos expertos piensan que una parte de
estos manglares protegidos podrían
desaparecer del mismo modo también
podría verse afectada la fauna autóctona
de la zona como por ejemplo las 30
especies distintas de algas que suponen
el hábitat de dugongos y tortugas
marinas especies ambas en peligro de
extinción
[Música]
y a las dudas medioambientales además
hay que sumarle ahora las dudas sobre la
viabilidad económica del proyecto a
corto y medio plazo debido bueno ya lo
sabéis a los efectos de coronavirus
antes de el coronavirus las salas de
exposiciones de ventas siempre estaban
llenas y las ventas iban muy bien
incluso algunas fases ya estaban
agotadas pero desde marzo las ventas han
caído más del 90% y ya apenas tenemos
visitantes miembros del equipo de ventas
de forest city paran y que ya se han
review claro dadas las circunstancias
ahora la gran duda es seguir adelante el
proyecto tal como estaba en mente o se
quedará simplemente como uno más de esos
numerosos grandes proyectos
inmobiliarios abocados al fracaso y se
ha levantado con un capital chino por
aquí y por allá el caso amigos es que
con este vídeo os hemos querido
presentar una de las formas más
ingeniosas con las que el programa one
by one row de xi jinping quiere extender
los tentáculos de tejido económico y
financiero de china pero habiendo
contado todo esto ahora turno para ti
qué opinas de todo este megaproyecto de
forest city como siempre déjanos tus
comentarios por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y recuerda si te ha gustado
este vídeo no olvides darle a like y
suscribirte a nuestro canal para no
perderte nada de lo nuevo que está por
llegar como siempre muchas gracias
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]